Dave Rubin is with me this morning all
right Dave you're a DeSantis guy what is
the number one priority number one issue
that will Propel him to the White House
is it his war on woke I hope it is
well the war on woke is a big reason but
I can tell you having not only moved
myself and my family but two companies
from California about a year and a half
ago to the free state of Florida that
everything is working here that's why
we've got about a million new people you
know since covid uh 1200 people a day
moving here are infrastructure is great
our streets are safe we don't have the
drugs and homeless I was in San
Francisco yesterday uh you know well
about that everything really is working
here and on the woke front yes we are
getting this gender craziness and this
race craziness out of the schools out of
our institutions I don't know that
there's any Governor maybe in modern
history that has said these are the 10
things let's say that I'm gonna do and
gone ahead and done every single one of
them and then of course they were been
rewarded at The Ballot Box let's
remember the guy in 2018 won won the
election to a guy who turned out to be a
meth addict by 30 000 votes he won
re-election by 1.6 million votes so the
people in Florida and everyone from the
rest of the country who are all
vacationing here we just set all sorts
of Records on that everyone recognizes
it and I the choice just seems very very
clear to me this isn't rocket science
however uh
DeSantis is going to is working on
abortion
uh is that going to be a major issue in
in 2024 because he's signing this
six-week abortion abortion rule could
that hurt him in the primaries
well I think in the primaries it
probably helps him because he's taking
Florida from 15 weeks which I personally
am comfortable with 15 weeks but that's
just my own opinion on abortion he's
taking it from 15 to six now in the
primaries you you kind of move right
that's going to help you with the base
because obviously the base is is large
part pro-life so I think it temporarily
helps him in that regard in a general it
might hurt him that that's realistic but
I've heard him talk about this many
times he has his personal belief on
abortion as a Catholic and he was voted
in and he's doing what he thinks is
right and the voters will have to decide
whether whether that's too far or just
enough or or not enough but again now
it's a state's rights issue so as
president it's not like he'd be laying
out a policy that would force every
state in the nation uh to have the six
weeks that we have here in Florida is it
the same with guns I'm not exactly sure
precisely what DeSantis position is on
guns but it seems like it's another
difficult issue for the Republicans what
so you
uh you know what I don't think so
actually I think most people you know
post covid post the summer of love and
watching so many of our Cities Burn I
think an awful lot of people have
changed their minds on guns I mean you
just have to look at the numbers of guns
that have been sold in America in the
last three or four years almost every
year it's a record so I'm not
particularly worried that the gun issue
is going to be is going to be an issue
uh you know we have a second amendment
the Second Amendment is what uh protects
the First Amendment and I think most
people do see that but again you didn't
you I personally wouldn't want Federal
mandates related to these things the
states can figure out what their little
minutia laws are yes it's a laboratory
the states are a laboratory for us so
scientists it's a beautiful thing ain't
it just that's why I'm here Dave Rubin
you're all right thanks very much for
joining us sir and we hope to see you
again real soon thank you very much if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell